Europe has a proud history of women
standing up for their rights
suffragettes in the UK and Scandinavia
campaigned for the right to vote at the
turn of the 20th century
today even if women have conquered the
polling booth in the workplace the fight
for equality continues women that
activism keeps driving change throughout
Europe the me2 movement announcing
sexual harassment and violence is just
the latest chapter of that fight gender
equality is one of the fundamental
principles of the European Union in
today's Europe women occupy the highest
political posts the European Parliament
is fighting to make sure women's voices
are heard
Simone Vail a noted feminist was the
first president of the directly elected
European Parliament she devoted herself
to defending women's rights both in
France and across the EU Nicole Fontaine
became the second female president in
1999 the European Parliament's Committee
on women's rights and gender equality
promotes equal representation equal pay
and women's financial independence but
there's more work to be done women only
make up 36% of members of the European
Parliament and that's still more than in
many national parliaments across Europe
the parliament has consistently called
for balanced electoral lists in European
elections it's also pushing for
political groups to adopt gender
mainstreaming strategies
you